hello and welcome to this video playing
Karen 84 he's yet to come on the school
board against me won three games let's
see okay for him
they do this but Wow yeah I mean if you
play if you play when you fall I guide
you according to to my repertoire
physically and I don't the the somewhat
rarer lines like this you don't get on
the board often and then you those
really have a hard time to remember how
things go okay yeah well this this this
cannot be bad yeah this looks like a
very strange type of French defense
going to retreat that voluntarily yeah
he has a hard time to get in c-five in
this position anyway I can even prepare
before so that c5 is even more difficult
to play okay and this is good news I was
thinking okay now I can even think about
B form simply stopping it
all together even though c4 is going to
be weak then
hmm it's still somewhat tempting I
believe okay now I don't know I will do
it just go a form get in a5 okay so now
the noise I need a knight on c5 this is
clear this is this is totally misplaced
ready so night C 1 D 3 I expect them to
play f6 at some point just you mean you
have to do something
oh wait actually I could take with the
deep one that is quite interesting but
he's got g5 which will completely tear
my no cam I sent it down don't do that
the night I get 95 in here
and this will be a bit awful I think
when you will always be on e6 and a6 and
it's night on c4 is looking good but it
doesn't attack much maybe you can play
Bishop h6 and go form the e3 Square it's
not like I have no weaknesses
maybe he wants to sacrifice there that's
an interesting trial
aconite takes him
hmm interesting by the way if I koji for
now isn't he basically forced to retreat
between on dat always at night each form
and like here 95 I will take f5 I guess
it should be fine if I get if he if he
has to play like 97 now it will be
really really nice for me to shoot g3
and then 95 what they mediate knows if
is oh he he goes for him goes for yam
goes for some counter-attack but it is
still a little bit hard to believe
always Queens traded even okay that
won't work not objectively speaking at
least
that this is this covers my piece is
covered one another quite quite nicely
yeah this area's a completely dead
Bishop absolutely absolutely
bad piece let's let's be precise here
like this
rook-a for age three and then is six
drops or Bishop c8 but then I just get
the King to g3 and win by been
technically
yeah this is one one way has put this
here and then 95 at the end now that
that opening result was just it was just
not that was not repairable at least I
mean maybe I allowed something that's
possible because it felt a bit
overextended at one point but let's say
this position must be excellent for
white I just have the big Center and he
has the both bishops here look look a
bit odd so okay this this yeah before I
think it's a good decision the engine
agrees now I don't know about he forward
generally getting this to a five makes
sense and now I just need to if I keep
control in this position let's see one
that's a cool engine to suggestion yet c
5d takes g5 yeah that shows what it what
you sometimes need to do to break down a
big center this is a cooled a Coulomb
line and three nights is 6 and then f6
so I can do everything so that things
open up and my pieces I mean this is a
little bit order it's very slow she went
to f6 but you know I'm not sure if he
maybe got enough there he takes this I
didn't like because of g5 but 94 is very
strong ok I didn't see that now I cannot
really cover this ok can do this but I
have
for years now and F takes now he has
some counterplay absolutely and the
engine is it's also giving this is OK
for black c5 is not able to play C fine
I have to take him then it gives this
okay night Patrol
yeah now Ichiro and there is no
sacrifice yeah as I said if he has to
retreat then things are basically gone
he had to take one of those
this is this opportunity that that I
should that the engine
it was giving here like c5 or so and
then he might have enough counterplay
okay guys thanks for watching